Hey everyone, this is Sadhart. Welcome
to my talk about the Blender MCP. Uh for
those of you who don't know what Blender
is or MCP is, I'm going to go through it
in a bit, but I'm going to talk about
how my experience was building this,
what I learned, and where I see it going
forward, especially for more creative
tools even outside of Blender. So, maybe
a little bit about me before we start.
I've been a designer and an engineer for
about 8 years now. I just like tinkering
with stuff. I ran my own product studio
for a while and this Blender MCP was a
result of some
experimentation. Um just but just before
we jump into it, you know, a lot of you
might be asking what is Blender? So
Blender is just a 3D tool. Think of it
as a generalist 3D tool. You can import
assets, you can animate them, you can
export them out to like a game engine.
So you can do all sorts of stuff in
Blender. You can create art, right? And
the UI kind of looks like this. It's
pretty complex if you see all the
different tabs everywhere. Uh on the top
over here, there's a bunch of things. On
the right over here, there's a bunch of
things. Each of these has like 10 tabs
inside it. So, it gets pretty complex,
which is the reason I myself could never
be a good 3D artist. I was too lazy to
go through all of these different tabs.
And u I I guess that was kind of my
motivation when I saw MCP. and uh I saw
that MCP could let your LLM talk to any
tool. My first response was, "Oh, wait.
Will this make Blender easier?" You
know, will this make a historically
complex tool easy to use? And so, just
to give you an idea of how it used to be
or even still is, it takes 5 hours to
build this donut. And this is a very
classic beginner's course that even I
did. But, uh this is the status quo,
right? It takes 5 hours to go through
this and build a tutorial. It should not
be this hard, right? And so the whole
idea behind Blender MCP uh is
essentially to let your LLM like Claude
or Chat GPT or whatever, right? Let them
talk to Blender, which is a complex tool
and let the LLM control Blender so that
it can make 3D scenes for you and you
just have to prompt. So in this example,
this is a demo I posted. Essentially,
I'm just saying make a dragon, right?
Have it guard a pot of gold and let's
see what it
does. Right. So you can see it kind of
gets the brief but also not the best.
But it it made an isometric room. It has
a dragon. It kind of gave it wings.
There's a pot of gold. It it made it in
what I think about 5 minutes. I would
have taken a lot longer to do something
like this to be honest. Uh so this is
this is where I think I'm going to talk
about a little bit more. So Blender MCP
launched to about 11 and a half stars on
GitHub at this moment. uh and it has
almost I think way more than 160K plus
downloads. A lot of people have used it.
A lot of people have built on top of it
and I'll show some examples in a
bit. But how how does it work exactly?
Right. So it's actually way more
straightforward than it
seems. So it's just essentially your
client which is claude or cursor or
whatever. It connects to Blender through
the MCP protocol. Right? If you haven't
seen what an MCP is, I feel like a lot
of people have been talking about it
even in this conference itself. But it
helps you, it's just a standardized
protocol that allows Blender to show to
the client, oh, this is what I can do.
Like, so that's the tools part of the
MCP that oh, these are the tools I have
and this is what I can do. And so the
LLM understands that and then uses those
tools. So how it uses those tools is in
Blender there's an add-on that I have
made to execute the scripts that the LLM
tells it to. So for example, Claude will
say make a dragon and it will call the
exact right tools to make those make
that dragon in Blender. Another big part
of it is the assets right so the
industry standard like rodin which is an
AI generated asset sketch fab and
polyhaven things like that are now
connected to the LLM and that can
basically now seamlessly if you write a
prompt to generate an asset inside
blender it can just do that right so the
client does all the heavy lifting
essentially yeah so I think blender is a
pretty big part I think the reason this
is possible in the first place is
because Blender has scripting right So
code can be executed inside Blender
which is a big part. Blender is pretty
flexible with also downloading assets
and importing and so that makes the life
like much easier
honestly with assets. Yeah, I think the
cool thing here is that this is just the
start but clients can connect to any
API. So for example, right now you can
write any prompt you want and it'll get
the right asset for you. You can say I
want a zombie and it'll get the right
asset for you. AI generated on the spot.
You can describe it however you want and
then the client is kind of the
orchestrator, right? So the cool thing
about this is I think that you can use
it in any tool you want. You know, it
could be claude, it could be cursor, it
could be wind surf, client, whatever you
like. Uh and you can use any language
you want with it, right? You can use
claude and chat gpt and gemini and
whatever you like. So I think this is
how it broadly functions together. If
you want more detail, there's always the
GitHub. But uh I think some learnings
while I was making this was that a tool
with scripting can remove a lot of the
heavy lifting. Like I mentioned the
Blender thing, right? Because Claude is
good at writing code, it can very easily
translate it to Blender and Blender can
execute that code and that can be for
modeling, for getting the right assets,
anything.
Um, the second part I learned was that
MCPS get really confused with tools. So,
I learned this the hard way where I had
to refactor the Blender MCP quite a few
times because I had about I think 14 or
15 tools and it kept getting confused on
what to use. So, tools can be something
like create a cube, create a sphere,
execute code, get this asset from Rodin
for example, right? So, how does it know
which one to choose? because it's a
little bit non-deterministic, right? So,
in that case, it's always better to kind
of keep the end user experience in mind
and making sure it's really lean and
every single tool is different from each
other so that Claude knows exactly which
tool to pick. Um, and a good segue from
that is don't bloat the UX just because
you can. I think this is more a learning
from making it open source which is just
I think there's a lot of features that
can be added but I think the reason
Blender MCP works is because it's lean
and a bit of a generalist tool so it can
get a lot done and another learning has
been that the models do get better the
underlying models. So while 3D models
aren't great yet and LLMs have a very
poor understanding of 3D in general
they're getting way better. So even in
the time I released it to the time it
was out, Gemini 2.5 came out and that
made it already 3x better, right? So I
think those are some things to keep in
mind when I'm building at least the next
MCP. Now, sure, now I've put this out in
the wild and now comes the creative
tools part, right? What's what's
changed? Uh how are people using it? So
historically, like I said, it's been
pretty complex to use 3D tools. And now
suddenly the barrier of access has
reduced. And so this is a scene I made
in 2 minutes. You know, just got the
right assets, AI generated all of them.
These assets don't exist otherwise.
They're all AI generated. And just place
them. Tell Claude how to place it. Tell
them I need a magical mushroom. And it
just creates everything from scratch.
And I can just take a picture of it
essentially.
This is u another
one where this is another one where
they're creating a cat and they're also
getting all the right AI generated
assets and then they animated it a
little bit to make it feel real. And you
can do all this in less than an hour now
where this would have taken way more
time earlier. Right? This is another one
where where they're providing reference
images. Right? So they just gave an
image of a living room and now it's
recreating that getting all the right
assets. Again this would have taken
quite a long time earlier to just make
this but now it's a matter of
minutes. Some other cool things this
person on Twitter they're generating
terrain. So they have an image which
they gave to the Blender MCP uh and
inside cursor they're trying to create
create this game on Blender and so it
generates the right terrain for you. It
even uses these nodes, right, which is
which itself has a learning curve to set
up these really complex textures and
normal bumps and so on. And so it does
that all of that for you just because
Blender can execute code,
right? This is I love this one. This is
a game that someone created. This is
essentially the idea is that they go
into someone's lungs and they have to
collect bone fragments to to win the
game to connect the rib cage together.
And so Blender MCP again was used to set
the scene to create assets. I I'll just
play it shortly.
[Music]
[Applause]
Yeah, I'll just leave it at that. Um, so
you can create games now. And this is uh
completely done in Blender MCP. It's a
pretty high fidelity
uh, you know, glossy this iridescent
material and a camera animation all done
in minutes by just prompting through AI,
right? Uh, so these are the things that
are being unlocked. Um, this is u
another cool thing that I saw that
people have been using it for. So, this
person prompted the MCP to create a
racing track and then animate the cars.
So, you can see on the side the MCP is
running and um on the right side this
Blender is running essentially. And so
this person created this. And now you
can see if I skip to the end a little
bit, this person now placed the camera
angle such that the cars feel like
they're feel like a movie. And then they
used runway to convert them to an actual
clip. So hey, here you can see it.
Whoops. Yeah, there you go. Yeah. So
they animated the camera and now this is
through runway. So it's another medium
that's been unlocked basically where
your even filmmakers or creators all
kinds of creators can use this not just
3D artists and this is just an example
of some donuts which are one short
prompts this is just you know like in a
minute uh it can may be uh made way
better of course but uh you know as a
start from 5 hours to a minute is not
too bad. So this is essentially
unlocking a whole
new world of creators to just come in
and when the barrier has been so high
now it's just gone and you can just
write what you want what's in your head
and get there with just enough prompting
right and so I think in general in a
broader sense MCPs are changing how
creative tools work and um just an
example of that I was trying to
experiment with this a little bit we
We're talking
about the client, right, being the
orchestrator where it talks to external
sources like the API. It talks to local
tools like Blender. So what if we extend
that an analogy a little bit and the
client orchestrates between all these
different things. So let's say the user
wants to make a game and people don't
come in with the intent of learning
Unity, right? They want to make a game
and people don't come in with the intent
of learning Ableton which is a music
creation software. They come in with the
intent of making music. So how do we
capture that intent and then transform
it so that this person doesn't have to
worry about the underlying tools but
also it can match their vision. So I
feel like MCPs are going to be a
fundamental glue that holds this thing
together and these LLMs are going to be
at the center at the intelligence at the
center of it. Right? So for example,
let's say I want to make a game. So I
tell it, oh, I want to make a game and
uh this this LLM is all they interface
with, right? And this LLM can then call
Blender and make an asset for the game,
the right assets. It can then call Unity
and make a whole game engine. Unity is a
game engine and so it can put it in add
collisions, add logic and make a whole
game out of it. It can call the right
APIs to get the right assets and animate
it and stuff like that. And it can also
call Ableton which will create the
soundtrack for the characters for the
game. Right? So you this person doesn't
really care about everything outside of
it. But now that MCP exists, the client
can literally just orchestrate between
all of these and choose the right tools
and make a game. So I don't think we're
very far away from this to be honest.
And u I made like a really short demo to
demonstrate how it could work. So in
this one I'm creating a dragon and I'm
just asking it to give a soundtrack. So
I also created the Ableton MCP which is
what you see on the bottom left which is
essentially you can prompt to create
music. So I thought let's try and
combine them and see what happens.
[Music]
[Applause]
So, you can see that it creates it gets
the dragon that I described. It creates
some sinister lighting because it's
supposed to be a villain. And it also
calls Ableton to create a soundtrack for
it. Sure, the quality might not be the
best in the world right now, but at the
same time, it's you can see it's only a
matter of time before it starts
stitching all these pieces together to
create something
insane. So, a few questions honestly
that this brings up for me personally is
that is it just going to be tools
talking to each other now, right? are
are people just going to interface with
the LLM and don't don't have to even
worry about learning the complex UI
beneath it because that's what seems to
be happening right it's a whole new
group of people that can come in and
create now and they can do it without
learning the UI behind it and are
creatives going to be more like
orchestra
conductors because because now I think
rather than knowing how to play the
instrument it's more important how to
get the vision in your head and place it
to the LLM so the LLM can execute it for
you and how you're conducting these
different pieces that go together. So
it's an interesting time I think to be a
creator and MCPs are pretty much right
at the center of it and I think some of
these examples like Blender MCP and
Ableton MCP are examples of that and
from that there have been spurred a lot
of MCPS for other creative tools like
I've seen for PostGis, Houdini, Unity,
Unreal Engine there have been so many.
So it's only a matter of time I feel
that you know this everyone can become a
creator which is pretty cool. Uh thank
you. Yeah, that's me and u yeah you can
find me on GitHub at Ahujas and you can
find me at Twitter at Sid Ahooj. Um yeah
so thank you thank you for coming to
this and if you have any thoughts please
leave them in the comments. Thank you.